Netflix's latest horror hit is thrilling viewers
even as it challenges the audience to figure
out what the heck is actually happening.
From blades to bugs and that wild final act,
here's our breakdown of what it all means
in the ending of The Perfection.
Spoilers ahead!
The Perfection's story is told in fragments
presented out of order.
That first becomes clear when we see Charlotte
and Lizzie's trip through China first through
Lizzie's eyes, drugged and without context,
and then from Charlotte's perspective.
Telling the story this way was a risky move
for director Richard Shepard and company,
but non-traditional story structure has paid
off in the past for movies like Reservoir
Dogs and Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind films for which planting uncertainty
in the audience leads to a satisfying payoff
and makes trying to guess what's going on
part of the fun.
The Perfection adds to this by attaching that
uncertainty to what should be a pretty simple
question in a horror picture: who's the monster
here?
It's only as the story nears its violent climax
that we truly understand that the real monster
is Anton, head of the Bachoff Academy.
The events of The Perfection may feature a
ton of twists and narrative shifts, but the
action and horror is all part of the journey
to the end.
A decade after leaving Bachoff Academy, Charlotte
is still trying to deal with the damage done
to her at the school.
From the start, we get the impression that
this woman has unresolved, possibly dangerous
mental issues.
The tension mounts as she heads to Shanghai
to meet her former teacher, Anton.
There, Charlotte falls back into the good
graces of the school's staff and gets seduced
by the new star pupil, Lizzie.
The two decide to take a trip into the Chinese
countryside together, and stuff starts to
get prescription strength weird.
On the trip, Charlotte drugs Lizzie with medication
she took from her mother, inducing a stomach
flu and hallucinations.
The two are kicked off their bus in the middle
of nowhere, and Charlotte convinces a delusional
Lizzie that her hand is full of bugs, prompting
Lizzie to go 127 Hours on herself with a cleaver.
We learn towards the very end of the film
that after Lizzie wakes up, Charlotte is still
with her.
She tells Lizzie that this was the only way
to free her from the Academy's brainwashing,
and that they'll turn their backs on her now
that she's no longer useful to them.
Charlotte returns home, and Lizzie tries to
go back to Bachoff.
Although Anton lets Lizzie stay at Bachoff
for awhile, he eventually kicks her out just
like Charlotte predicted.
Bitter and lost, Lizzie proceeds to break
into Charlotte's house, intent on killing
her.
Then Lizzie brings Charlotte back to the Bachoff
Academy as a prisoner.
She's chained up and forced to play for the
staff and misses one note.
As the faculty close in on her, though, they
start falling to the floor because Lizzie
has drugged their drinks.
Through the final flashback, we return to
Charlotte's house and see Lizzie finally acknowledging
that Charlotte was right she'd been brainwashed,
and they both agree that the creeps at Bachoff
need to be stopped.
In the final shots of the movie, we see Charlotte
and Lizzie playing a single cello together,
each with one arm.
Anton, meanwhile, is dismembered, blinded,
and castrated, hooked up to a feeding tube,
being forced to listen.
It's a bizarre, yet emotional moment for both
the audience and for Lizzie and Charlotte.
The room they're in, the Chapel, had always
been a sacred place for Anton.
It's where he dreamed of hearing perfection.
Veteran students were brought in there to
play a perfect piece, only to be punished
when they missed a note.
"We don't make mistakes here, not when we
represent the academy."
With all his limbs gone and his eyes and mouth
sewn shut, Anton is essentially locked in
a mental prison where he's forced to listen
to Charlotte and Lizzie play forever.
What if they miss a note?
Who cares!
They're playing for themselves now, and Anton
has no choice but to endure it.
It probably goes without saying that this
movie is rooted deeply in recent social phenomena
like the Time's Up and #MeToo movements, and
it brings a level of fictionalized catharsis
in the form of a gruesome conclusion.
This is a long-running tradition in the horror
genre: a character or force representing a
real-world fear is brought down by the forces
of good.
Alien famously used its xenomorphs as an allegory
for sexual violence, and Get Out pretty brilliantly
turned racism and gentrification into a Frankenstein
monstrosity.
In the same way, The Perfection tackles institutionalized
abuse, gaslighting, and toxic misuse of power.
When Charlotte and Lizzie force a severely
de-limbed Anton to listen to them play, they're
not just reclaiming their power, they're asserting
their self-worth over an abusive power structure
that spent years objectifying them.
If you saw the trailer for The Perfection,
you were probably pretty intrigued.
You were also probably wildly thrown off when
you watched the actual movie.
The trailer for The Perfection made it out
to be something it was decidedly not: a bug
infestation freakout picture.
It made heavy use of the scene when, stranded
on the side of the road, Lizzie screams at
Charlotte about the bugs crawling inside of
her arm.
Beyond that, we're not given much information
as to what the film is about, besides being
informed that Charlotte is the kind of person
who's always prepared in case a meat cleaver
might come in, wait for it, handy.
"You know what you have to do."
Netflix was pretty cautious about not giving
anything away in the trailer, and it makes
sense.
The movie's emotional gravity is predicated
on the audience having as little information
as possible.
And in a messed up sort of way, it's kind
of fitting that a movie based on surprising
twists was marketed through yet another twist.
With everything happening onscreen, the audience
could pretty easily overlook some of the musical
cues in The Perfection.
The thing is, some of that music is pretty
important.
For one thing, Anton is pretty consistently
associated with Mozart's Requiem in D minor.
It's a bombastic, foreboding series of pieces,
the most dramatic of which, "Dies Irae," plays
when Anton approaches Lizzie in the driveway,
unaware that he's about to be horribly dismembered
as a result of his own misdeeds.
Aside from the song's lyrics about judgement
and reckoning, you could go even deeper with
this choice of music.
The story goes that Mozart told his wife that
he was writing the mass for his own funeral.
When he died before completing the Requiem,
he left the completion of the composition
to one of his former assistants.
Intentional or not, it's a fitting song to
play as Anton arrives at his eventual doom
in a school which will soon be controlled
by his own former students.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.